in this video we're going to learn about
the obligations of u.s citizenship
obligations are actions that citizens
are required to fulfill or they'll face
punishment by law
unlike the responsibilities of
citizenship we talked about in the last
video which are voluntary actions taken
by good citizens the obligations of
citizenship are not optional
so what are some of these obligations
first citizens must obey the law they're
bound to abide by the rules that have
been made by elected representatives in
government
next
citizens over the age of 18
are required to serve on juries
the constitution guarantees people
who've been accused of a crime the right
to a trial by a jury of their peers so
citizens are obligated to show up and be
those peers when summoned
although not everyone who is summoned
will be selected to serve on a jury
citizens are also obligated to pay their
taxes every year by april 15th according
to state local and federal laws
what other obligations do citizens have
young citizens are required to attend
school as children and teenagers
most states require students to go to
school from about the age of 5 or 6 to
about 16 to 18 although the exact ages
and requirements differ from state to
state
the last two obligations are to defend
the constitution and the country when
called upon
these are in the naturalization oath
that new citizens must take to defend
the constitution and the laws of the
united states means to be loyal to the
system of government
not to try to overthrow the government
or support a particular ruler rather
than the system described in the
constitution
citizens are also obligated to defend
the country in a combat or non-combat
capacity when called upon by the
government
although at this time only men or people
assigned mail at birth must register for
selective service between the ages of 18
and 26.
so now that we've learned about the
obligations of citizenship let's do a
couple of examples
see if you can identify which obligation
each person in the scenario is or is not
meeting
okay first up michelle is an avid
bicyclist he likes to work every day
he knows that he could save about five
minutes off his commute if he cuts
through a college campus and rides on
the sidewalks
however in new york city it's illegal
for bicyclists over the age of 13 to
ride on sidewalks as bikes are vehicles
so michelle sticks to the bike paths on
the street
alright so pause the video here and
think about
which obligation michelle is following
if you said obeying the law you're right
okay next one naomi is 14 and starts
tricking her mom into thinking she's
taking the bus but instead goes to the
library to read all day she gets away
with it for three days before her mom
finds out
which obligation was naomi neglecting
she's neglecting her obligation to
attend school
last one
to deal with the shortage of personnel
in a war the us government drafts
thousands of men one of these men jon
stewart reports for enlistment with the
u.s marine corps at the young age of 19.
which obligation is he meeting
this one is the obligation to defend the
country when called upon
all right that's all for now keep
practicing in the exercise for this
lesson